kelly dodd shared some text message
exchanges between the two of you you
reached out to her
after the news hit why did you feel like
reaching out to kelly
kelly and i are neighbors we live in the
same town we have similar friends
i mean her ex-husband's new girlfriend
like does all my land like it's a small
town we live in a very small town we're
neighbors
um we're going to run into each other
and i just didn't want to leave it with
any bad blood like
we haven't seen each other much i ran
into her once at a restaurant and i was
just like hey you know what
this sucks this is hard you saw the text
messages because now they're out there
um you know if you want to talk and and
i meant it you know like
i give people second chances 10th
chances
that's who i am you know i don't like to
hold on to anger and hate
i'm not that person you know a big part
of my program is making amends and
moving on
and letting go so i was just like hey
it's over we're neighbors
what is what is and then and then to see
it back there and it's like
your fake story lines and like still
sober still gay
i want to read you the caption she
posted along with the screenshots
she said i can't believe this bronwyn
has the audacity to text me
she went on a podcast she said she was
fired from the show because we all
didn't like her because she's gay
not because she's a horrible person not
because she treated everyone like
and made no effort to be friends with us
not because she went on a press tour and
made horrible accusations about us
calling
all of us homophobes and racist not
because she's a terrible mother
not because she's a horrible person to
her husband the only reason she was
fired is because she is gay
what a [ __ ] nutjob classic narcissist
that's a mouthful wow that's a lot um i
i didn't say that i didn't say i was
fired because i was gay
i'm not sure what you haven't this is
your first interview since
firing you released a statement and now
this so there was no podcast in the in
between
i'm not sure what she's first of all i
don't know what she's referring to i
didn't you know i didn't say that
um but i have learned during the season
she takes a lot of things i haven't said
and makes it into things i have
so i'm not surprised i'm used to it it's
like okay
um and like all the rest of it they've
said it this whole time
you know they've called me a narcissist
they said i'm a bat and those are easy
digs you know
i'm a huge advocate for mental health i
don't like when people
use clinical diagnosis as insults
you know if you don't like me then come
up with another word
don't weaponize mental health please um
you know i'm a great mom and i know that
i know i'm a great mom i have great kids
it's like the proof is in the pudding my
kids are great
uh what else god there was a lot in
there there was a lot in there well what
do you make of
she in her response in the text message
she blamed you
for why she was no longer on the show as
well um i think it's hard to take
accountability and when you're
angry it's easier to blame someone else
than to take accountability i think
people do that in a lot of things in
their lives
it's easier to be angry than sad
and so i'm not going to take that
personally she cut off the part where i
said i hope you have a beautiful life
and then she actually wrote back
something pretty sweet too like yeah you
too
she didn't post that part so it actually
when i left the message i'm like
okay that ended nicely if we run into
each other at mastros it'll be okay
whoops and then instagram happens
did you reach out to the other ladies i
don't really have a relationship with
elizabeth and i don't see her
we don't have any similar friends and no
you know no
how do you uh feel about shannon emily
and gina
being kind of the survivor of
this big change i think it's i honestly
i think it's weird um
you know gina and gina i get gina was
very like
you know whatever um emily i think
tamara judge said it best is like
watching paint dry
i i agree i'm like i know her in real
life and i'm like you were
eeyore you know um
and then shannon i think shannon's good
because you get the older
long-term viewers you know that's good
for bringing them back i think the
dynamics with the new and the old will
be interesting you know how there's a
great casting decision
i see like the idea of heather and gina
is going to be it's going to be
interesting you think bringing heather
back
is a good call oh yeah for sure
definitely
i think they even should have gone
further in all honesty but
you know if you're gonna recast and
you're gonna go the direction of the
and i know the new cast members so if
you're going that direction
i just think that it's gonna be it's
gonna be an interesting
dynamic you have like young hot
rich beautiful cool liberal
and then you know conservative trump
supporters it's gonna be an interesting
dynamic
uh these newbies you're referencing i
have to assume
the one is noella i'm not i don't know i
can't say anything you're not you
you do know but you won't confirm
because you don't want to get in trouble
um but uh how would you feel if your
friend were to join the show in that way
so i will tell you i'm not going to say
who's on next year but i will say
i'm very close to one of the people and
she was one of the first phone calls i
made
and i said the truth i am so happy for
you
you are such a beautiful soul i'm so i'm
so happy that the rest of the world is
gonna
get to meet you you deserve all the
beautiful things but this is
really hard for me you know
and that's the truth i can be happy for
my friend and sad for myself
and i'm working through that i call
tamara tamara and i are close
and i'm like this hurts you know like
i'm happy for her
but i'm so sad for myself so i don't
know i think it'll go in waves too when
she's filming i'm not and i'm not
that's going to be hard when she's at
bravocon and i'm at home it's going to
be devastating
so i am trying to work that out on my
own
you know right now and not be jealous
or petty because i don't want that but
like it's been 48 hours so i still
meditate and sit on this but she isn't
the the person i'm talking about
is amazing bravo's lucky to have her
she is born for this and just a
beautiful
shining star if the phone call came to
be like hey
your friend is throwing an event or
doing a dinner we'd love for you to pop
by would you
come in check in on the girls absolutely
um i would love to
i would love to bring a date i would
love to normalize seeing two women
together in a conservative town
i mean i think representation matters
and i absolutely would
do that in a heartbeat one i love the
crew i
know i think that's the people that i'm
gonna miss the most two i want to
support my friend
in any way i can and three if i could
you know be there
as an out gay woman which i never got to
film as that would be beautiful
[Music]
you